how's it goin man my name is piraiba
welcome back to some more bully this
game really took a large turn the other
time when we left the city and now we
can't like go to the carnival we can
like do stuff and we can go in the paper
sorry but we're actually gonna start the
quest next to the school and only over
girls thank you for telling me about all
lemons by the way it seems like old line
Sweden is teabagging
but whoops nice fall it's also like we
have another word called it's really bad
and I probably shouldn't explain it to
people if kids are watching that's a
Yoda bag
what's up Melvin sorry ok after that's
how I'll explain Jimmy listen yeah some
ruffians took it upon themselves to
steal my grottoes and Greg after sheets
and won't return them no way we're
playing tonight the whole situation is
untenable my channel are sad sad I'm
distraught role playing is the high
point of human achievement Wow
if I never really got playing in video
games I was young it was a couple's
role-playing Sunday tonight's first
honest
hippie how much but wait here and you
can have your pick of my wenches great
what when chess is that girls
well I'll escape Wow oh my god
[ __ ] yeah grenades escape but anyway
Holly that [ __ ]
no now it's working again you ruin all
the fun you [ __ ] stop paying me [ __ ]
what's with the unfair fighting what's
with the unfair [ __ ] running you
pressed there we go give me that that's
for me yet skating away skating away
skating away because I'm not gay
low-riding
it's running like a beer you're lucky
I'm a busy woman
wait what he's are here where is he oh
yes what's up nibs that's right you've
got something of mountains give it up
all right all right sure threw in the
nuts you kick him in the nuts okay
stupid yeah I said get up
that was awkward ago what what ain't do
anything well I got kicked in the nuts
come back here you scamp's
[Music]
hey Farland
go up go up there we go
hello friends he's taller than him just
[ __ ] take gay guys incredibly funny
for me yeah I'm sorry I took a picture
of that alright GMG character sheet
alright we got one more yes I'll have
here
I'm Riley oh it's batch smacking back
into Packer
nerd smacking time yecch that's right
get up
now [ __ ] sake just kill him there we go
this might come in handy
you don't say Billy you're a genius
that's not even your name is it hey lady
what's up breakfast [ __ ] get out I like
you turn hey girl breakfast
I got brothers I wasn't me it wasn't me
I swear to [ __ ] god I swear to god it
was a babe what's my evil twin
what and there we go you're welcome and
the house yes the house no respect
[ __ ] I always knew I could do
it oh let's knew I had it in me always
know I could do it
okay we got a return to our base I think
it's not it's a new quest over here then
right it's not [ __ ] taking yeah over
at the girls dorm a lot it's gonna be
good it's gonna be alright it's gonna be
good
all right what do we got the diary oh no
not that girl like yeah hey Beatrice
what's wrong hey rose yeah secondly mr.
hatrocks saw me writing in my diary
during class and he took it and he
locked it in his desk and he says he's
gonna give it to the principal tomorrow
if anyone sees what's in there I won't
just die it's really personal yeah well
nothing like having the whole school
knowing your deepest secrets makes your
teenage years go by in a flash yeah well
you'll soon find out me what in the
diary I talk a lot about you and me what
there is no you and me yeah yeah there
is see first you rescued my notes from
Andy and no we fell in love and oh you
brought me flowers and wrote me poetry
and show this kinder sensitive side that
soon the whole world is gonna know about
we're like
doomed lovers no we're not I'll get your
book back then we can kiss the cold
sores aren't contagious once they start
to scab over good good scatting over
it's a really romantic word got that
once a scab over it's all good to go
when the girls have the herpes you don't
go with it
I was trying every what I bribed you
would not have been looking at me like
that
only over a little boy ollie over that
guy all right the world is Pula it's a
really bad word in Swedish don't use it
and it means bad things so don't do that
kids got it today and basically it's the
same word that a lot of people using
video games winning for example when you
play I don't know whatever the [ __ ] and
you want to you want to bring a group of
people to you you say pull them but in a
Swedish grammar you say lot so it sounds
wrong the more you know I'm even talking
about this go to bed daddy all right so
we're just climbing cool I didn't get
that fine through the window or what
what's that what's he doing it's
demanding on my tit baby right out of it
stop stop stop
you're not faster than me I have a skate
barn don't even think you're cool ow
all right here it is check the staff
room [ __ ] and it's downstairs [ __ ] even
more difficult time
look at this flap up don't even give a
[ __ ] I'm I'm here to look at your momma
your mom naked pics every person here
Southern's at my place Megan is there on
yourself oh [ __ ] what what in the hell
what what what the [ __ ] just happened
I don't even know I don't even know if I
want to know okay I made it in here
somehow so buggy today what the [ __ ] is
going on that new Jimmy boy is so bad
bad teeth bad hair bad smell bad
attitude and yet there's something about
him that I just saw alluring I told
Bucky about how I felt and he didn't
seem happy at all that makes me a little
sad because Bucky spins Fred sound and
hate to think that something or someone
in this life is not treating him well I
wonder who oh I knew it I walked by him
today and he looked at me he's such a
fries radical how I'd love to pair his
electrons the whole thought of us making
sweet organic chemistry just sends
shivers down yeah beautiful it's
beautiful
share an electron why not why the [ __ ]
not
I mean they're free you can't buy an
electron or can you can you can you're
alright let's give this harvest garlic
kiss can you just throw an apple at her
top [ __ ] sake
[Music]
all right so since we failed with that
quest I guess we got to go in Tom now
watch my speed yeah it's really fast all
right we're going to town I'm glad you
have the skateboard it's for sure the
coolest thing
hi president I've been realizing that I
am I have only been doing side quest all
along this is what I'm supposed to be
but I didn't want to go here so I guess
I had to go here but whatever I'm sorry
if I didn't realize prep challenge there
we go main quest finally boxing term has
glass-tile boxing maybe I can use this
to my advantage okay
how all right what's up my man round one
fight how
alright Chad I'm sorry but you're going
down I don't like your face I don't like
her close your hand your gloves are you
really actually it's the same gloves as
my gloves but hey they're still really
ugly there we go yeah finally are we
gonna find more people okay fine fine
see if I care
there we go all right one more one more
on this [ __ ] how many really I don't
you gotta keep fighting this lives haha
alright that's enough
well alright I won't give me much yeah
give me my money
hmm there's a little problem your
parents have to be members of the board
for you to be eligible tell you what old
chap will give you that old abandoned
beach house should be nice once you
clean it up Kenny sounds like the guy
from Smosh Anthony Ben don't deny Oh I
earned the beach come house I'd say
that's a that's a win
I mean that's a beach house you save
location online alright so I don't have
to go to school all the [ __ ] time I
guess that's pretty I take it I take it
for sure my work here is done
alright so we got a new question here I
guess like I better go there and save in
that a Balaban for today
ha oh here we go
perfect exactly what I wanted today
Geronimo
can I escape in the sand I can best game
ever
my BJ what's that swim around don't have
the boys alright second today
I don't know why I'm doing this but I'm
doing it what do I win
a tiny swimsuit that does not sound good
at all
[Music]
hey you look like a scarecrow I'm no
threat to you peasant hey what's up I'm
taking a picture of that but did you say
something did you say something
that's right stay down [ __ ] all right
let's check out this beach house thing
what do we got it's not bad not too
shabby
what're your breasts think do you like
it let's do the same here and then that
was all for today like a paranoid since
guy comes with today and I've seen
except sorry I mean love your brows but
you know I did tell them here we go it
looks like someone [ __ ] on a stick and
send it to me thank thank you for doing
that